continuing on with the series of season
critiques we've made it to season seven
from the title you can see i'm not
particularly fond of this season and i
was kind of surprised that through this
poll i ran most people didn't
necessarily dislike the season
for this analysis i'll go into three
main aspects as to why i think it's so
bad which all relate to the writing and
to me that was their primary culprit of
the season also a lot of people
critiquing the show to say that the
writing in general is bad as a vague
term but for this video i'll go into
depth about which aspects of the writing
have declined
first we have the writing being rushed
and this is obviously a general
statement to make but this flaw leads to
a lot of negative side effects
which are the pacing being overtly fast
a lack of intriguing dialogue to slow
down that pace
not developing and exploring the
subplots to their full potential or just
start up abandoning plot lines
altogether
before i dive deeper into those flaws
and show examples i'll briefly explain
why the writing was rushed in the first
place since david and dan by this time
were becoming very popular they were
getting massive offers from netflix and
disney to make content for them in
response to that and partially because
of burnout david and dan decided to make
two shortened seasons instead of the 10
seasons that hbo and george rr martin
wanted dumb and dumber even refused the
help of more writers from hbo and wanted
to take practically full ownership of
game of thrones
this paired with the lack of source
material led to a downfall on the
writing now this brings us back to the
side effects of that rushed writing
the first side effect is the issue of
pacing
generally the speed of the pace for a
show or movie is determined by how fast
you move through the plots
in season 7 we have so many story events
that are crunched into just seven
episodes
meanwhile in the earlier seasons we
would have like a few major story events
in the course of 10 episodes and why is
this a bad thing you may ask well that's
because you need to have a good balance
of build up and payoff and to also have
enough time for your characters to grow
a prime example of perfect pacing is in
season 2 where throughout the king's
landing subplot tyrion is learning how
to be a great hand while also being
tasked with taking on the massive
obstacle of defending king's landing
from stannis
that is proper build-up to a major story
event that thoroughly develops turing as
a character but if the king's landing
subplot was similar to season 7 we would
have tyrion defending the kingdom having
to marry sansa and then being accused of
joffrey's death and being tried for it
this is how season seven is for daenerys
she arrives to dragonstone goes through
numerous battles meets the king of the
north and falls in love with him has to
save everyone from the white hunt and
meets with cersei for a ceasefire all in
the course of one season
that's pretty nuts
and any scenes we get with her that
includes dialogue is mostly tyrion
saying repetitive stuff like don't burn
down king's landing forehead and don't
use your dragons at all you'd be flying
around the open seas alone for who knows
how long i wouldn't be alone
i would have drogon viserion and rhaegal
what can anyone do to them which always
leads to the same outcome of dany hating
tyrion and ignoring his idiotic advice
that's not character development
actually think about it how does
daenerys change as a character
throughout season seven really the only
major change to her is her falling in
love with jon snow and seemingly
becoming more compassionate
and again that's extremely rushed you're
telling me these two people fell in love
in practically four scenes
along with jon snow being one of the
main reasons her dragon got killed
going from daenerys being the most
depressed she's probably ever felt at
the loss of a child to then having the
hots for john in the course of 20
minutes is like emotional whiplash from
cracked pacing
you need to slow down the pace so that
the characters can breathe and express
how they feel
make it to where daenerys is in a dark
place and jon pulls her out of the
depths of depression and that's how they
fall in love
that could also act as proper
foreshadowing to the mad queen arc but
yeah i doubt david and dan actually
thought that much about it another issue
with the pacing is that we don't really
have a lot of in-between scenes to make
it seem like time has passed for example
in season 1 when most of our characters
are traveling to king's landing there
are a lot of scenes along the journey to
portray the passage of time along with
having great character and world
building dialogue in those scenes but if
you think about that journey they get
from winterfell to king's landing in
just one episode
meanwhile in season seven all the main
characters teleport to king's landing
for the ceasefire negotiations between
the transition of one episode the reason
why this passage of time feels contrived
is that there are no in-between dialogue
scenes during that journey and that's a
massive missed opportunity given how
many main characters were on the ship
heading to king's landing the
possibility for riveting dialogue scenes
were endless but again since dave and
dan are rushing to the conclusion and
overall story events the pacing is
artificially fast when it should be
slower with the inclusion of more
intriguing dialogue like the earlier
seasons
for another side effect of rushed
writing we have the underdevelopment of
subplots or just abandoning them all
together
for this point i'll jump right into an
example and that's the underdevelopment
of cersei's subplots
throughout season 6 david and dan seem
to be alluding to there being a big
uprising every one of us is poor and
powerless and yet together
we can overthrow an empire
you might find it difficult to rule over
millions who want you dead
half the city will starve when winter
comes the other half will plot to
overthrow you
the queen slaughters babies so when
cersei destroys the sept and everyone
seemingly hates her there's a big
opportunity to further develop that
subplot to show the difficulties of
running a kingdom while everyone hates
you but instead for season 7 that whole
potential area of conflict vanishes and
that leaves a very limited number of
scenes for cersei since now her only
relevancy to the story is fighting
daenerys the way this ties into the
writing being rushed is that david and
dan just didn't give themselves enough
time to properly type all the loose ends
so they just wanted to focus on the main
storyline this also plays into heavily
simplifying different aspects of the
story to make it easier to write like
not utilizing time travel with bran's
powers or anything besides crows really
arya's whole faceless assassin skill set
the azor ahai prophecy overall magic and
numerous other abandoned plot lines it's
inherently easier to write a story with
less complex elements at play along with
dozens of plot lines and different
aspects of the story that you have to
pay off this in turn makes season 7
significantly shallower and more
superficial because with a selective
focus on a couple areas of the story it
in turn makes the show seem much worse
when compared to the earlier seasons
when everything was thoroughly thought
out and explored down to the finest
details
moving on to another glaring flaw in the
writing is that it is extremely
contrived
what i mean by this is that dumb and
dumber forced different plot points in
the story to happen with very little
explanation or logic
the most prevalent example of this is
the journey beyond the wall to kidnap a
white
the overall logic behind this plot point
makes practically no sense because in
what world would cersei of all people
actually help her enemy
especially considering that this plan is
coming from tyrion who quote unquote
understands his sister but with this
flawed and horrendous logic we now have
two big set pieces of action and drama
that are suddenly forced into existence
even if the story as according to george
rr martin was leading there the
execution was completely butchered by
dumb and dumber
in getting there they completely
compromised tyrion and the intellect of
every character involved
then if you look at the episode more
closely why didn't they just use
daenerys dragons to fly in and swoop up
some whites in the dragon's claws
or at least use the dragon as a form of
immediate extraction how did jon and his
entourage think that they could get
their hands on a white without any white
walkers noticing
oh because dumb and dumber wanted an
epic action scene to instill a false
sense of entertainment that is unearned
then when zooming in even closer to
examine the logistics of that action
scene literally every character should
have died but were protected by plot
armor
how convenient that the night king
waited for the ice to re-freeze for 24
hours when it was shown that the whites
can just swim
or how convenient that the night king
didn't harpoon drogon who was a much
easier target to hit and who had every
main character on him that opposed him
season 7 is basically packed to the
literal brim with these types of moments
and scenes filled with plot armor
contrivances and conveniences
like let's have a big action scene where
daenerys rolls and smokes everyone with
drogon oh but we don't want to kill
jaime yet or have him get captured so
let's force a stupid scenario where he
actually survives
and it would also like a scene where
tyrion and cersei reunite to show off
their acting chops which requires jon
snow to act like a dumbass
overall if most of the story events are
forced into existence then nothing feels
natural and it calls attention to the
characters doing stupid things to move
the plot forward
it becomes a big issue of the story
driving the characters instead of the
characters driving the story with their
coherent
decisions for the last big issue of
writing we have the butchering of
characters
in other words dumb and dumber not
knowing how to write the main characters
at all
which is kind of sad considering that by
default dave and dan had to be extremely
familiar with the source material to
have even gotten this far in making the
show
but anyways first we have jon snow
a character that has devolved into just
parroting the same lines over and over
and has no real character development
past season 6.
this especially gets worse in season 8
but it started in season 7.
all the dialogue that relates to his
character solely exists to only move the
plot forward either he'll drone on about
needing to fight the night king needing
more allies or just needing anything the
protagonists in general need when i left
winterfell i told you we need allies or
we will die but more importantly we need
allies i told you we needed allies we
need allies
powerful allies if we're gonna be allies
in this war it's important for the
northerners to see us as allies a very
shocking difference to how he was in the
earlier seasons where it felt like he
had an actual personality
next we have arya a character who
criminally has literally nothing to do
the whole season
dumb and dumber sidelined her character
in the stupid force drama between her
and her sister sansa
which again links back to the contrived
writing of forcing these two characters
into a conflict that can easily be
solved by brand clearing up the
confusion
which also happens off-screen to play up
a contrived drama in theo's conclusion
with littlefinger where the audience
doesn't know what's happening going back
to aria though i don't know when she
made the transition between being a
psychopath who threatens her own sister
more than lannister's soldiers that's
pretty wild when you think about it
while we're here we have sansa who's
similar to arya doesn't really have
anything to do for the whole season
she becomes the acting queen of the
north but the show never gives her any
obstacles overcome while in that
position to grow her character
the only obstacles being arya and
littlefinger who seemingly was afk for
most of the season until they killed him
so not a very interesting obstacle to
begin with
yet again another character who has very
minimal things to do thanks to the
rushed writing
on to the next stark child we have bran
a character who is now a complete
douchebag who doesn't care about
anything which is solidified by the fact
that he doesn't even thank mira reed for
everything she's done like come on man
seriously
brandon wasn't really that likable to
begin with but he now just becomes
insufferable and has nothing to offer to
the show but to tell people that jon is
a targaryen
which is just saddening from an audience
perspective due to him not using any of
his powers besides his apparent crow
fetish
moving over to daenerys she is for the
most part unchanged but any dialogue
scenes with potential development are
either romancing jon or arguing with
tyrion
if anything the scenes with tyrion makes
it feel like she's regressing because
she's rightfully choosing to ignore his
terrible advice
i guess the writers wanted to allude to
her becoming angrier in doing her own
thing but in the process they ruined
tyrion which brings us to tyrion a
character who was once the smartest in
the show who now becomes just as
intelligent as the person writing him
the fact that tyrion doesn't have a
single line of good advice as an advisor
is pretty tilting from telling daenerys
to not use her dragons instead of just
using them strategically
assaulting casterly rock instead of you
know defending highgarden the most
valuable place in westeros due to how
much food and money they have
wanting her to let everyone die beyond
the wall because it's too dangerous
and actually thinking that cersei would
help them fight against the army of the
dead along with the plan to kidnap a
white
the only good advice turin really gave
was to spare the tarlys and to form an
alliance with the north but that doesn't
salvage the behemoth amount of bad
advice he's given
the worst part about all of this is that
the show doesn't set up tyrion to become
more stupid or however the hell that can
happen to be honest he does however
become more worn down after killing his
father but that doesn't mean he loses
his iq
what i'm getting at here is it would at
least be understandable if there was a
reason behind tyrion's decline in brain
functionality i suppose we should say
goodbye
one idiot to another
but it just comes across as dumb and
dumber not being smart enough to write
his character
so now that leaves us with just two more
characters cersei and jaime
for cersei in comparison to seasons five
and six she takes a big step down
because in those prior seasons she was
basically the protagonist of her own
story and she had a lot of great scenes
that humanized her character and made us
sympathize with her but now she's back
as a primary antagonist so she kind of
loses those excess scenes that made us
care for her as a character
there are a couple scenes with her
having a romance with jamie which is
fine but the clear standout is her
getting revenge on the lauria sand
it's a fantastic scene but it mostly
acts as payoff for season 5 along with
it giving more clout to euron which is
never a good thing
but in general for this season cersei
kind of becomes that stereotypical
villain and it feels like she loses the
depths she had in the earlier seasons
then finally we have jaime lannister
and surprisingly this is the only
character i liked in the season because
he actually had a character arc
not everyone needs a full blown
character arc in one season and most of
the time it happens over the span of
multiple seasons
but none of the other main characters
really have that over season 7 and 8
especially since the writing just gets
worse
but going back to jaime at the start of
season 7 he's mostly devoted to cersei
by the end he decides to fight for what
is right and defend the living from the
dead i think that's an overall good
transition and it stays true to his
character being honorable he was also
involved with the spells of war and in
that battle i think jaime offered a
great perspective to how devastating
daenerys could be in war
despite him having a contrived exit from
that sequence
but overall a lot of the characters take
a dramatic downturn in quality whether
it's doing stupid things that are out of
character or becoming so dull that
they're just unlikable
it creates a massive divide for fans
following and loving these characters
and it's especially noticeable when they
used to be much better
writing in essence is the basic
foundation of shows and movies and if
it's fundamentally flawed then the end
result of the show is just going to be
bad no matter how pretty the special
effects are or how cool the action may
seem i think the grounded and realistic
tone in the first four seasons are much
better than the bombardment of action
scene after action scene and the story
moving at ludicrous speed
the slow paced detailed nature with the
occasional build up to an epic action
scene is peak game of thrones enjoyment
for me and not what season 7 is
i can understand why some people may say
that the season is ok but i just think
it's thrusted into the bad region
primarily because of the writing
regardless though i hope you enjoyed the
video and let me know what you think
about season 7 in the comments
you